-Welcome back.
-Thank you.
-You look good, bud.
I'm so excited
to be on "Jimmy Kimmel."
It's so good.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a different --
[ Cymbal crash ]
That's a different --
-Oh, it's -- oh --
-It's a different show.
-Oh, the beard.
-Yeah, all the -- yeah.
-You're trying to --
You're trying to grow one.
That's cute.
You're trying to grow one,
that's cute.
-It's -- It's not real.
-Hopefully it'll
fill in for you.
[ Laughter ]
Keep it up, keep it up.
Keep hope alive.
-Oh, keep hope alive.
-Keep hope alive.
-It's so good to see you, bud.
-And you, as well.
-I love having you on.
How's the little boy?
How's your --
-He's amazing.
-Yeah, how old is he? 7?
-7. 7.
-Yeah.
-Asking all kinds of questions.
I think he's realizing
he's much smarter than I am.
-Mm.
-So, right now, he'll ask me
questions to see
if I know the answer.
I'm like, "Of course
I know the answer, kid.
But you need to learn it
'cause I'm older."
Then I'll go to the bathroom
and I'll google it.
[ Laughter ]
See what he's talking about.
But now, he's getting so wise,
what he's doing is --
I say, "Well, tell me.
You know the answer."
And he'll tell me
the wrong answer.
I said, "Yes, that's it."
He's like,
"That's not the right answer."
[ Laughter ]
At 7 years old, pretty smart.
-Yeah, he's chasing you.
-Pretty smart, yeah.
-Yeah, he's smart.
By the way,
I want to talk about this.
Because I know you --
Atlanta is where you're based,
but you also have a place
in Wyoming.
-Right.
The only Black man there.
[ Laughter ]
-The only Black man in Wyoming.
-That's right.
-Congratulations on that,
by the way.
-Thank you.
-Hey, that's a big honor.
-I feel like a pioneer.
-That's a hon -- you really are.
Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But you -- you posted
this photo of a giant moose...
-Yeah.
-...in your backyard.
-Look at this.
This made me laugh.
It's just --
It's just, your eye says it all.
-Yeah.
-What in the world?
[ Laughter ]
-No, that's --
that's at the back door.
And notice,
I'm up on the balcony.
'Cause when they show up,
I get the hell out of the way.
I'm just like -- and they're
so quiet and majestic,
they'll just come up out of
the woods, out of nowhere.
And I used to --
there's a fire pit over here
that I like to sit and write,
and I would sit there for --
You know,
when I first bought the place,
I'd sit there and write.
Then these jokers
started showing up.
I was like, "No."
-"No."
-"You were here first.
You can have it."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's true.
Look at this.
-Yeah.
-They're massive.
-That's right outside
the window.
-Beautiful.
-Yeah.
-Holy moly.
-You know what he's saying.
-Hm?
-"Come out here,
I'll kick your ass."
-Yeah, exactly, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly what he's saying.
-But you also -- you gave --
you brought a video for us.
There was another --
I mean,
you're like a wildlife guy.
You're like --
you're like Bear Grylls.
-Bear Grylls.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you're like the guy
who likes outdoorsy stuff.
-I don't -- I don't want to be.
When I was --
I'm sitting in the garage,
working on one of my little
toy planes, and the doors open,
and all the other stuff,
and I thought,
"Oh, this is so cute.
It's so beautiful."
And then I -- I --
You go back to Atlanta,
and I get some video.
This is the video I saw
of this thing
walking right past the door.
-Yeah, take a look at this.
-Yeah.
-Here's the video.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Yeah.
-Dude, look at that thing.
-Does that frighten you?
Does that --
-What do you mean,
"Does that frighten me?"
[ Laughter ]
I'm not Bear Grylls for real.
-No, I know, I know.
But I'm saying, but --
-Yeah, but all the neighbors,
they think it's so cute.
All my little white neighbors,
they're like, "Oh, my gosh.
I just want everybody to know
there's been a bear sighting
in the neighborhood."
[ Laughter ]
"So, please
don't leave any food out.
And be sure if you see the bear,
make noise so they should --
you won't startle them,
especially if they're
with their cubs.
It's so great."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-But what --
-"And if you find yourself
in danger,
just get bigger than them."
I'm like, "I'm already 6'6".
I'm already big, right?"
-What would you do if a bear --
-Die, die.
-No, no, no, no.
-No.
-No, you have --
[ Laughter ]
-No, I'm saying to survive,
to survive?
-To survive, you're supposed
to do all those things.
But my Black ass is gonna run.
I'm telling you right now.
[ Laughter ]
I'm dead.
I've got a bad knee at 53.
I'm out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-A bad knee.
-A bad --
My son will be very well off,
but I'm not gonna do it.
I'm not gonna do it.
-I saw that you recently --
you threw a party for everyone
at Tyler Perry Studios.
-Yeah.
-You got to be
so proud of that thing.
I'm just so psyched.
What a great story, by the way.
Speaking of googling stuff,
you want to just google
a great story
of what this man's done.
But you threw a rager
for everyone that --
-A rave?
-A rager.
-Rager? Okay.
-Yeah.
-A difference.
Make it clear.
-No, no.
-Yes, yes, yes, yes.
-Yeah, you don't know rager?
-Yeah, and I haven't had --
We don't say that much
in Atlanta.
[ Laughter ]
-Like, "We're throwing a rager."
-"Throwing a rager!"
No, no, no, no, no, no.
-Yeah. You don't do that?
[ Laughter ]
-We have a party.
-Yeah.
-We have a good time.
-"You got to throw a rager."
-"Rager, man.
I'm trying."
-Yeah.
You have --
-"Grow a beard
and have a rager."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But it's a big party
is what a rager is.
-Yes, got it.
Okay.
-Yeah. What happens
at a Tyler Perry party?
What do you need to have
a successful party?
-Lots of alcohol.
-Mm.
-Free food, drink, eat,
great entertainment.
You know,
I asked Usher to perform.
He came to perform.
-Yeah, Usher played.
-Usher, Fantasia,
you know, H.E.R. showed up.
And Tevin Campbell.
Was really, really amazing.
But it's not legal in Atlanta,
but I want to have a weed truck.
And they told me I couldn't
do it because I --
-No, yeah.
No, you can't. Yeah.
All right, but those are
the types of things.
-Yeah.
Can you imagine a weed truck?
You walk up to the truck and
get whatever edible you want.
It would be really cool.
I'm thinking about going into
that business.
-No.
-No why?
-It's just -- you'll dominate,
and that'll just be the thing.
And they'll be --
No, I need you to do --
stay focused on all the fun,
creative things you're doing.
-No, weed trucks and ragers.
I'm changing my life at 53.
[ Laughter ]
-I just changed your life.
-You just did it, man.
You just did it.
-Last time you were here,
we were talking -- you were
thinking about retiring Madea.
-Yeah.
-And then -- and then you said,
"Well, you know what?
I'm thinking about un-retiring,
because people need
entertainment, and they need..."
-Joy and laughter.
-...to laugh and I go,
"Yeah, please do that."
-Yeah.
-And then you made this movie,
"A Madea Homecoming."
-Yeah.
-It was a giant global hit.
-I mean, massive.
-Number-one in many countries.
Yeah, yeah.
-Number one?
-Yeah.
-How does it feel when you
go like, "Yeah --"
'Cause at one point,
you were like,
"I'm not gonna do that again."
-Yeah.
But I -- more than what I felt,
it was more like her saying,
"What the hell I told ya?
I told ya, I dominate this --
So, yeah.
It's me, baby."
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, I don't know.
I don't know.
Listen, as long as people --
Again, as long as people want
to see her, she'll be around.
-I think Madea --
Madea should have a weed --
a gummy truck.
-And a rager.
[ Laughter ]
-She should have a --
-That would be --
that would be a great truck,
called "High as Herl."
[ Laughter ]
"High as Herl."
That's it.
-High as Herl.
High as Herl.
That's it.
New flavor, new flavor.
-Dude, come on, you make dreams
come true, all right?
I want to talk more with
Tyler Perry when we come back.
Stick around.
-This beard, man, this beard.